the country of japan knows that
cryptocurrencies are the future they are
looking at various ways that they can
actually reduce the friction in making
sure that the right assets are listed on
the exchanges within their jurisdiction
now we're getting news that they are
creating a green list of 18 different
cryptocurrency coins that will be ready
to be listed on exchanges without
screening those lists include bitcoin
and ethereum now in order to be added to
this green list which is being overseen
by the japan virtual and crypto assets
exchange association known as the jvcea
you simply have to be listed on three
exchanges in japan and at least one of
the trading platforms have to actually
have listed that digital asset for at
least six months now of course there's
various assets that are on here and it's
all the normal culprits the largest
assets in the world bitcoin ethereum xrp
litecoin and many others now of course
many people will say why do we need the
government to go ahead and create these
types of lists but what we are watching
is that exchanges they want clarity what
can i list what can i not how should i
go about evaluating now that there's
going to be a green list it simply tells
them these are the ones that are
pre-approved get these listed
immediately so that the users in our
country can go ahead and start to
transact in them now we've got a quote
here from the vice chairman of the jvcea
where he said users have also flocked to
overseas exchanges our goal is to
eliminate the time it takes to list the
token and bring the industry closer to
global standards this is important to
understand because japan not only
realizes that cryptocurrencies are the
future they realize that a global
competition is underway you either
innovate or you die and the country of
japan just signaled they want to be a
leader they want to be at the forefront
of this revolution every country
eventually will come to this conclusion
the question is who's going to do it
first and japan seems to want to be a
leader so seeing them move forward with
this it's all about that action boss hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time